a triple bowl stainless steel sink um  one that's not deep even though i'm tall  or want it because i'm tall  deep sinks give me a backache so that  was that another thing that was  interesting now a lot of people do it  but at the time we put our microwave low  so the kids could take care of  themselves you know the sooner these  kids could take care of themselves  and then all of our dishes and things  were low so that the kids could reach  them so that was interesting  um and then heading over here now all my  spices are empty right now because we're  getting ready to go on vacation but i  put them all out so they were easy  easily visible and a little step up so  you could see  all the different spices and then this i  thought was pretty revolutionary  pans are always like hard to deal with  so what i did was i put drawers of pants  our pins were in drawers